in the meantime author and columnist
mark Stein joins us tonight to chew this
over does this surprise you mark no not
at all Tucker by the way if you're Road
testing new labels for the creepy porn
lawyer I I think we should go with
creepy porn extortionists you late you I
congratulate you Tucker because you
grasped the essence of this character in
a way that CNN and MSNBC and all the
rest of the media didn't as you know we
were talking as you mentioned six months
ago after that interview about the
reality of the situation here that
stormy Daniels is stripping on an
18-inch bar in Richmond Virginia hoping
to get a few dollar bills and maybe the
occasional five tucked in her garter
while he's sitting there in a $4,000
suit and making exploratory trips to
Iowa and New Hampshire and in a way it
ties in with everything else you've been
talking about this last hour the way the
media have been pushing things that are
obviously phony down the throats of the
American people and no matter how often
they're basically like a kind of army of
Yosemite Sam's they keep sticking the
dynamite down their own pants and no
matter how often it's Delta's pants are
dynamited and Anderson Cooper's pants
are dynamited and Don LeMans pants are
dynamited they'll fall for the very next
creepy porn extortionist who comes along
but but why is it I notice a theme here
with avenatti and Harvey Weinstein and
many of these presidential candidates
what about the Democratic Party and
their handmaidens in the media attract
them to the worst people in the world
it's always the the unusually bad people
they wind up celebrating why is that
well I think it's to do something Alan
Dershowitz was talking about earlier
today that once you've decided on the
outcome you become actively invested in
willingly
now I'm an I'm an old Fleet Street chap
so I love sex scandals yes for the sex
the minute the minute stormy Daniels was
presented as a campaign finance reform
that's the least interesting sex I've
ever heard about
that's a fetish that only Democrats and
the media can get into and the the idea
that but look nothing else is going
seems to be clear enough in the Russia
collusion thing
why don't we merge it with stormy
Daniels by making this a campaign
finance reform infraction that's a
losing proposition for anyone other than
CNN such a good point I can say this
sincerely about creepy port lawyer he
really was creepy in all the years I've
worked with our stage manager Louie the
only time I've seen him used Purell is
one creepy porn lawyer was here no I'm
not kidding no we touched him by
accident and then used it he's that
dirty no Mark Steyn no no you wear a
hazmat suit next time Tucker you don't
people by the way I would almost never
say I you know I feel bad about saying
you describing something took place
off-camera but that really did happen
it's stuck with me ever since I've never
met a guest in 22 years of doing this
who was more personally menacing and
dark than that guy but the question you
came up with that label and the question
is why did you get the essence of the
man and CNN dis and MSNBC and the rest
decided to glorify him and say here head
to Iowa and New Hampshire question
you're looking great for 20/20 rating
why sure to do that this is the point as
always mark Stein thank you thanks a lot
tucker great to be with you